[Musique]
Glenn Albrecht, bonsoir. Nous vous
recevons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle Serview. Nous sommes en
direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succintement ?
Merci de m'avoir avec vous. Je m'appelle
Glenn Holbrecht. Je suis un philosophe
environnemental australien. J'ai créé le
concept de sol nostalgie
qui apparaît dans mon livre qui vient
d'être publié en français en France aux
éditions Les liens qui libèrent et je
travaille comme philosophe
environnemental
tout au long de ma carrière.
Mon dernier poste était professeur de
durabilité à l'université de Murdock à
PT.
Est-ce que vous connaissez la devise de
sœur Murdoc ?
C'est pas le Murdoc de la presse Murdoc,
c'est sœur Walter Murdock, un esséiste.
et c'était un écrivain célèbre et un
esséiste australien, mais je ne connais
pas son il a il avait
un proverbe sur l'éducation
qu'une une bonne éducation doit vous
apprendre à à penser par vous-même et ne
pas avaler la mode que le monde moderne
essaie de vous faire avaler. Je résume
ça trivialement. Vous connaissiez ça ?
Non. Je savais que c'était un homme très
intelligent, qu'il avait de l'esprit,
mais je ne l'ai connu que par le nom de
l'université Murdoc. Et je dois dire aux
gens, non, il s'agit pas de Robert
Murdoc, c'est sœur Walter Murdoc. Donc,
je suis très heureux d'être associé à
cette université et à ce
Il y avait il y avait combien de de
pays, combien d'élèves sur votre
université ?
Dernière fois que j'y étais, c'était
environ 20000 mais j'ai pris ma retraite
en 2014 et je ne sais pas quels sont les
chiffres actuels
et je ne connais pas le destin de Mdock
University en 2020. En 2020, il y avait
si si les chiffres sont bons, plus de
17000 étudiants, 1700 enseignants et 90
nationalités représenté. Quand vous
enseignez là-bas la perception des
émotions concernant
le collapse écologique, le changement du
biotope, quelle était la réaction de vos
élèves ?
C'était intéressant.
Lorsque j'ai présenté la première fois
ces idées, cette nouvelle partie de
l'enseignement, j'ai tenté de les faire
rentrer dans un
un programme déjà classique euh de
sujets classiques sur l'environnement.
Donc je donnais souvent une conférence
séparée
comme faisant partie de mes activités de
philosophes
et c'est ainsi que c'est je parlais pas
seulement à mes étudiants mais à toute
l'université. J'ai entendu des idées
comme la solastalgie, la symbiène, le
symbiocène et d'autres idées qui que
j'ai développé pour les tester pour la
première fois face à un public pour voir
comment il réagissait. C'est toujours
difficile d'introduire de nouvelles
idées dans un monde qui est déjà très
occupé et plein de ce que les gens
pensent conventionnellement.
Est-ce que vous pouvez nous nous définir
ce que c'est le nous redéfinir ce que
c'est la la seule nostalgie ? Est-ce que
c'est un état dépressif ? Est-ce que
c'est une nouvelle mémétique culturelle
? Est-ce que c'est
nouveau ? Je le décrirai comme
une expérience vécue, une expérience
émotionnelle
qui relie
l'état du territoire de la région,
du lieu où l'on habite à un certain état
d'esprit que je décrirai comme
de la désolation,
une détresse parce que on a plus de
plaisir ou de confort.
d'un endroit qui était chéri et aimé par
ses résidents. Donc c'est défini comme
une définition
une certaine un mal du pays lorsque vous
êtes dans votre propre pays.
Et plus techniquement, c'est
l'expérience vécue
d'un changement négatif dans votre
environnement propre infligé.
euh
cette détresse que vous ressentez
parce qu'il y a cette différence entre
vous et votre domicile, votre maison.
Par contraste avec ce concept de
nostalgie qui avait été défini par
Hoffer en 1688,
c'est le mals quand on est loin de chez
vous et que vous souhaitez retourner
chez vous. Vous êtes par exemple loin
dans un environnement étranger et votre
mal est tellement puissant
que ça peut affecter votre santé mentale
et physique.
Le résultat,
le la solution pour guérir le mals,
c'est de vous rapatrier vers la patrie,
tel que c'était décrit à cette époque.
La nostalgie, c'est la différence, c'est
l'opp c'est l'opposé.
Vous êtes chez vous et c'est votre
environnement qui vous quitte et vous en
êtes triste. Donc la solution
à la sol nostalgie,
c'est de réparer, restaurer
l'environnement qui était le vôtre pour
vous faire revenir vers un état
précédent de plénitude et
d'appartenance.
Si si on narrive pas à si on narrive pas
à
restaurer le le biotope environnemental
autour de chez soi, qu'est-ce qui se
passe psychologiquement et qu'est-ce que
ça peut générer chez les gens ? Est-ce
que ça génère de l'agressivité ? Est-ce
que ça génère de des comportements
lymphatiques démissionnaires ? Est-ce
que ça génère d'autres attitudes ?
Ça peut générer une variété de
réactions.
L'idée que l'on a besoin de restaurer
quelque chose pour que ça soit la
réplique de ce que c'était le passé ne
fait pas partie de la définition de la
seule nostalgie. On peut réparer,
restaurer
dans une certaine mesure mais pour créer
un nouvel environnement qui donne
un certain degré de plénitude,
d'identité et de but dans la vie.
Donc, il n'y a pas de connexion
obligatoire avec le passé dans ce
concept de sol nostalgie. Donc ce n'est
pas de la nostalgie, c'est par
définition
un état
qui peut être amélioré à l'avenir mais
pas une réplique exacte du passé.
Toutefois, si votre environnement est
euh ruiné par
des des mines d'excavation, de des
guerres ou des choses de ce genre, ça
peut être véritablement un changement
important dans votre environnement parce
qu'il sera difficile de s'en occuper
sans éliminer les causes. Et dans le cas
de la solalgie, dans ma définition,
j'avais à l'esprit la cause qui était
les mines à ciel ouvert dans la région
de la vallée du Hunter. En Australie,
ces mines de charbon qui s'étendent sur
des centaines de kilomètres carrés. Et
la solution à cette seule nostalgie,
c'était de lutter contre les mines de
charbon. Donc voilà la réaction, cette
réaction peut-être tout qui va de
plant des arbres, faisant en sorte que
l'endroit reverdisse à il faut lutter
contre les multinationales et le
gouvernement australien. Si on veut
alléger la seule nostalgie et revenir à
un environnement qui nous donne
véritablement du confort,
c'est c'est pas trop tard de
d'entreprendre ce type d'attitude, de
restaurer, de planter des arbres,
d'essayer de vivre en communauté avec un
capitalisme qui est galopant,
sans
euh boundaries without any sans
contrôle, sans sans sans sans toutes ces
choses-là, est-ce que la société qui
consomme de façon exponentielle n'est
pas devenue tellement importante que je
dirais des pensées utopistes ou de prise
de conscience de la solalgie ? C'est
c'est pas un peu trop tard ?
Si c'était utopique, ça serait pas trop
tard parce que l'utopie est un état
inatteignable même s'il est désirable.
Je dirais que la seule nostalgie,
c'est une réaction réaliste
à une situation dans lesquelles les
humains se sont placés et en tant que
tel, ils peuvent s'en sortir.
Ça devient une question de volonté.
La raison pour laquelle
j'ai cette position pour dire que ce
n'est pas trop tard, c'est que en tant
que vieille IPI, j'ai vécu les années 60
et 70 à une époque où les gens pensaient
que un changement radical pouvait
prendre place.
Et c'était le moment où le mur de Berlin
s'est décroulé alors que les gens disait
"Non, non, ça se produirait jamais, ça
sera jamais
enlevé ce mur de Berlin." Et le
lendemain, il y avait des images de
jeunes garçons, de jeunes filles avec
des marteaux qui le réduisaient en petit
bout. Alors, on ne peut pas me dire que
le changement ne peut pas se produire et
peut pas se produire rapidement. Je l'ai
vu se produire. Nous luttions dans les
années 60 70 contre l'anilation
nucléaire. J'ai manifesté contre les
Français qui faisaient exploser des
bombes atomiques à Miruroa. Donc moi,
j'ai manifesté contre les Américains
parce qu'ils avaient commencé la guerre
du Vietnam et l'Australie y a pris part.
Donc
je peux voir moi que cette expérience
vécue du changement social et du
potentiel du changement social est
quelque chose qui reste avec nous et je
le vois dans ces générations, la
génération Z,
une superbe génération
qui n'ont pas leur part dans le présent
et ils ne savent pas, ils pensent que
les choses ne s'amélioreront pas, sauf
s'il les améliorent eux-mêmes. Et moi,
j'aimerais bien y participer aussi à ce
changement. Même si j'ai maintenant 67
ans,
je suis à la retraite mais je me
considère comme un vieil IPI, prêt à
être radicalisé à tout moment et
j'espère que ce processus de lutte va
continuer.
Je vais me faire l'avocat du diable.
Est-ce que vous connaissez le volume des
produits dérivés sur les marchés
financiers ? Est-ce que vous connaissez
l'interconnexion des produits dérivés ou
des produits financiers avec les fond de
retraite ? Est-ce que vous connaissez le
l'intrication
du système financier dans notre propre
vie de tous les jours ?
Je connais le contexte australien plutôt
bien. J'ai vu ces problèmes avec les
tentatives de limiter les retraites en
France.
pour accroître l'âge à partir duquel les
gens peuvent partir à la retraite. J'ai
vu les réactions de colère sociale et je
peux comprendre
les les gens
qui ont ce genre de réaction.
Donc, mais comme j'ai dit, ces problèmes
sont
moins importante que le réchauffement
climatique.
Ce sont des problèmes qui vont réduire à
rien les fonds de retraite et l'économie
de pays. Donc, en ce qui me concerne, la
proportionnalité de l'effort est
nécessaire.
Il faut mettre les meilleurs efforts
dans les choses qui sont les plus
importantes. Je peux comprendre pourquoi
certaines personnes s'arrêtent au niveau
des fonds de pension et combien d'argent
ils auront à l'avenir. Mais je pense
qu'il est possible pour que les gens
voient plus loin et plus haut.
Voir que les fonds de pension n'auront
aucun sens dans un monde où il n'y aura
plus de système climatique viable.
ou un système environnemental
avec des extinctions de masse des
espèces.
On arrive au point où les feux de
brousse australien sont extraordinaires.
Les quand vos maisons brûlent et bien
vos priorités changent.
Comment comment vous percevez l'attitude
du pouvoir politique, l'attitude du
pouvoir industriel face aux défis, aux
menaces que représente le changement du
biotop ? Est-ce que vous considérez
qu'ils sont à la barre du bateau pour
gérer malant
ce qui a géré ? Est-ce qu'ils font une
politique symptomatique ? Est-ce qu'ils
ont un prisme de lecture à long terme ou
est-ce qu'ils sont devenus totalement
mégalomanes ?
d'une mission divine pour continuer ce
système qui les a toujours engraissé.
Je dois être d'accord avec votre
remarque conclusive.
J'appelle ça le corpalisme.
Corrompre.
Donc c'est plus que
corrompre, ça peut être simplement une
égratinure.
Une égratinure sur votre disque viny ou
quand il y a trop de poussière sur votre
CD. Le corpalisme, ça signifie que vous
détruisez systématiquement les
fondations de la vie.
Donc le système politique économique que
nous avons créé
est maintenant dans un processus
d'autodestruction.
Et je ne peux parler que du système
politique australien parce que je vis en
Australie, non pas parce que je suis un
quelqu'un qui fait de la science
politique. Mon observation c'est qu'on a
un cas classique d'une classe politique
qui est corrompue au point où ils ne
gouvernent pas, ils sont gouvernés. les
forces qui les gouvernent,
les entreprises
multinational mais
une grande partie sont des entreprises
nationales australiennes avec beaucoup
d'investissements dans le les carburants
fossiles.
Et donc, on a un système similaire à
celui des États-Unis où une corruption
de grande échelle a lieu par des dons
aux partis politiques avec des petits
sacs pleins, des valises pleines
d'argent.
Et le résultat c'est qu'on a un système
de gouvernance qui est dans le déni
scientifiques auquel on doit faire face.
Mais s'est tellement intéressé à soi,
tellement égoïste
dans cette
direction, c'est qu'il faut beaucoup de
mauvaise foi pour arriver devant le
peuple et dire que on est inquiet du
futur de ces enfants et de ces
petits-enfants. Moi, je dis que c'est un
gouvernement d'effondrement. C'est pas
simplement un effondrement de la
démocratie, mais je vois le
corrompalisme comme une nouvelle force
qui détruit les fondements de la vie euh
pour les autres êtres humains et toutes
les autres formes de vie avec laquelle
nous partageons ce globe.
Comment vous anticipez le futur de la
classe politique ? Est-ce que vous
pensez que la classe politique va se
tendre, va se durcir, va se rédire face
au peuple et rédire face au nouveaux
défis en continuant à prolonger ce
schéma intellectuel ou est-ce que vous
pensez que la population va réussir à
prendre conscience et ensuite à faire
prendre conscience des choses au à la
caste politique ?
Le public devient conscient. L'exemple
que je vous ai donné il y a un instant
sur les feux de brousse en Australie,
c'est un mécanisme où soudain,
il y a eu un changement dans le régime à
part disant que oh c'est pas tellement
important jusqu'au moment où c'est
devenu la chose la plus importante dans
la vie des gens.
Et il est estimé que de tiers du public
australien sont affectés directement ou
indirectement par les feux.
Et vraiment c'est un coup terrible à
l'économie
sans mentionner des choses comme les
pertes de vie,
les pertes de bien des gens.
L'estimation c'est un milliard au plus
de d'animaux, d'oiseaux, d'espèces,
les koala, les kangourous.
Le résultat, on voit le public
faire pression sur les le personnel
politique tel qu'on ne l'a pas vu depuis
une décennie.
On lutte depuis plus longtemps qu'une
décennie. Mais bon, le public,
il y a une toute petite minorité
d'Australiens qui tentaient de changer
le climat politique
avec toute la science, tout ce lobbying,
tout ce travail.
Les activistes
n'ont réussi à rien finalement, mais les
feux de brousse, eux ont changé tout en
un instant. C'est comme un instant tel
que celui de la chute du mur de Berlin.
Et nous les scientifiques, nous tentons
de changer de tenter de comprendre ce
changement de régime.
Et voilà, il n'y a plus de contrôle sur
ce qui se passe.
Je pense que ce n'est pas une réaction à
court terme. Je pense que maintenant
c'est quelque chose qui est enchassé
dans l'esprit du public. Notre premier
ministre est un fidèle de l'Église
pentecoiste.
Je ne pense pas qu'il soit mal à l'aise
avec l'idée que le monde pourrait
prendre fin demain et que lui et ses
enfants disparaîtront avec lui. Il y
croit
et
que ce les vrais croyants seront sauvés
et que ceux qui pensent mal et bien
brûleront si ce n'est enfer, du moins
dans les forêts d'ecalyptus de
l'Australie. Le résultat, ce genre de
dirigeant n'a pas sa place pour l'avenir
de l'Australie.
Et euh
tout ce qu'il fait, c'est du marketing.
Il répète les mêmes choses au sujet de
la grandeur de la croissance économique
et
de son budget.
C'est la répétition de ses mantras.
C'est pas simplement ennuyeux pour les
Australiens, c'est vraiment agressif
parce que
on est à se mesure avec des problèmes de
vie et de mort.
Je pense que cette idée du régime,
changement de régime
et bien il y a une une nouvelle
dimension qui est arrivée dans l'esprit
des gens. savoir à voir avec le
changement climatique mais aussi avec
tout l'environnement.
C'est l'idée que nous ne pouvons plus
continuer à être
les plus grands exportateurs de pétrole
du monde.
C'est la fin de l'idée que l'Australie
peut exister comme une société de
service et tout un porté de Chine. Les
feux de brousse
et le virus. récent,
on fait clairement apparaître que un
monde globalisé est un monde dangereux
et
il suffit qu'une chose aille de travers
et tout s'écroule.
une société plus résiliente aurait plus
de diversité
euh se reposerait moins sur des flux
tendus et serait et n'aurait pas besoin
d'une économie de flux tendu.
Effectivement,
c'est une réponse longue à votre
question, mais
il n'est pas trop tard.
Et la science nous dit que si nous
agissons
avec de la force, de l'intelligence, de
la rapidité maintenant
et que nous le faisons pendant une
dizaine d'années
sans arrêter,
nous pouvons nous mettre sur un chemin
qui nous permettra d'éviter
l'effondrement climatique.
Et
pour moi, c'est une alerte claire.
les scientifiques du monde que si nous
ne le faisons pas, nous serons dans des
graves problèmes.
Est-ce que vous avez vu le film
Idiocratie ?
Euh non,
on vous le conseille. Euh euh pour vous
le résumer euh succintement et
trivialement, euh
un monde où les gens ne sont pas très
futés, pas très intelligents, dirigés
par une caste politique tout aussi euh
stupide et et
stupide.
Est-ce que vous pensez que le 21e siècle
la masse de gens pris dans leur
problème, pris dans une distance par
rapport au biotop, pris par
la vitesse du monde ? Est-ce que cette
masse de votants ne va pas se mettre à
voter pour le plus populiste, pour celui
qui dira "Je suis le président du
pouvoir d'achat, je suis le président
qui va vous permettre de vous chauffer à
tant de degrés. Votez pour moi, ça ira
mieux." Est-ce que vous pensez pas que
cette masse facilement
instrumentalisable est trop importante
pour pouvoir renverser les choses ?
cette masse qui est hypnotisée.
Oui, j'accepte le fait que ça se
produit.
C'est un problème mondial massif auquel
il faut faire face.
Le but d'écrire ce livre pour moi, ça a
été de subvertir ce processus à ma
manière, de l'attaquer à travers les
émotions.
Ce que la science n'arrive pas à faire,
n'arrive pas à faire de changement
significatifs.
La classe politique et les bureaucrates
sont tellement investis dans le passé
pour que il fasse à devenir un
changement. Donc je suis engagé dans ce
qu'on peut appeler une pensée
révolutionnaire.
C'est la troisème guerre mondiale, c'est
la guerre des émotions. Ça semble
tellement binaire mais je suis prêt à
pénétrer dans une tragédie grec. Mais
les forces du mal et de la destruction
font face aux forces du bien et de la
création. Et on est vraiment à ce point
de rupture.
Et donc comme je le donne dans le
l'exemple de l'Australie, on est passé
d'un état où on était des gens qui
marchaient en dormant à une marche dans
l'éveil.
Donc soit on est séduit et hypnotisé
par les spin doctors ou alors pour ces
gens-là les feux ne font pas de
différence. On naaprend même pas de ces
désastres écologiques et
environnementaux.
On utilise le mot sans précédent
et la science nous dit que rien de tel
ne s'est produit précédemment dans
l'histoire de l'Australie.
C'est sans précédent. Et si ça ne peut
pas faire advenir le changement, et bien
je serai tout à fait en ligne avec vous.
quelques bonnes bouteilles de vin
sur un rocking chair, c'est tout ce
qu'on pourrait faire. Mais moi, je fais
tout ce que je peux pour soulager la
douleur parce que c'est tout ce qui aura
sens.
Kowakowski, lexiste polonais a dit un
jour qu'il croyait dans la loi de
l'errein de la loi des reins du progrès
et les scientifiques nous disent que
l'âge de la réponse arrive.
La seule chose que l'on peut faire pour
aider le progrès, c'est de
s'asseoir devant les
les voitures et les et les wagons et les
empêcher d'avancer.
Je crois que l'avenir ne se déroulera
que d'une seule manière. Si c'est pas le
progrès,
moi
rien n'est inévitable pour moi. Nous
sommes capables de générer
une dynamique de créativité pour pouvoir
faire face à ces problèmes. Et
tomber dans une paralysie perpétuelle,
une anxiété, une angoisse, un désespoir,
c'est la garantie que ce genre de
d'avenir se produira.
Et bien c'est ce que je dis de
l'écoparalysie,
le fait de tomber dans une forme de
de débilité
où je ne serais plus capable de faire
quoi que ce soit pour changer cette
situation.
Tétanie,
je suis pas très certain.
Paral by the stuff.
Pardon, j'ai une autre question. Comment
on fait pour mettre le monde en
psychothérapie ? Parce que quand je vous
écoute, j'ai l'impression qu'on est dans
une société profondément malade avec des
gens parfaitement adaptés à cette
société profondément malade. La question
c'est comment on fait pour mettre ce
monde sous psychothérapie ou lui lui lui
montrer le qu' qu'il est profondément
malade ? On s'occupe physiquement des
politiciens.
On organise des manifes de IPI, on fume
des pétards, on a des fleurs dans les
cheveux. On on fait quoi ou on tombe
dans le le radicalisme, l'activisme
radical comme extinction rébellion.
Est-ce que vous soutenez Extinction
rébellion ? Extinction
rébellion est une des réactions.
Je suis surpris et soulagé que mon
travail
parle plus qu'au
politicien et
aux universitaires.
Il y a des rockers avétal et d'autres
qui ont adopté mes points de vue et des
artistes, des musiciens, d'autres types
de gens créatifs, des réalisateurs de
cinéma
et même d'autres
reconceptualisent ce problème comme
faisant partie des émotions. C'est pas
un problème biomédical qui exige une
thérapie ou des médicaments. exige une
confrontation avec nous-même
et une situation inconfortable où on se
met à analyser le rôle que l'humanité
joue dans sa propre destruction
et c'est exprimé à travers le modèle
actuel de l'économie et de l'industrie,
la production et de la consommation que
nous avons.
Je vois cette solution comme en fait il
y a beaucoup de façons de se réveiller
et Wilson appel cela la biophilie. Si la
biophilie c'est un moyen, on peut le
pousser aussi dans la direction opposée.
On peut devenir
des nécrophiles,
apprécier la la destruction autour de
nous, en tirer du plaisir. Mais
finalement en tant que espèce sociale
qui a besoin
de beaucoup de temps pour que les jeunes
puisse arriver à maturité,
notre capacité de voir l'opposé
de l'échide
de la nécrophilie,
l'éconécrophilie
si on veut lui donner un nom.
Et donc je dirais que plus on va du côté
du négatif, du côté de la destruction,
de plus en plus on se rapproche des gens
qui se rendent compte qu'il y a un
opposé, une tendance opposée qui nous
permett de réussir en tant qu'espèce
avec d'autres espèces sur terre.
Et j'écris sur le côté opposé
du des émotions négatives qui nous
submergent actuellement.
Elles ne sont négatives que parce que
nous avons compris
et dans notre inconscient
ces sentiments opposés.
On ne peut pas avoir ces sentiments euh
négatifs, déprimants, sans avoir un
sentiment
d'un lieu désirable pour que les
émotions positives puissent apparaître.
Pour le comprendre et l'apprécier, j'ai
créé ce symbiène qui est l'opposé de
l'entropocène. Je vois l'anthropocène
comme euh
un compte-rendu de l'état où nous sommes
actuellement. Nous sommes une espèce
dominante sur la planète où on est en
train de diriger tous les processus qui
se produisent actuellement sur Terre.
Mais dans le même temps,
comme les tribus de l'entropocine,
nous devenons des échecs patents en tant
qu'espèce et le lien doit être fait de
façon logique, mais doit être fait aussi
de d'autres façons
à travers les arts créatifs,
comme je l'ai mentionné précédemment, on
peut commencer par euh donner des
expressions
au négatif par le heavy metal ou le punk
rock.
par l'art, par d'autres formes de
créativité humaine. C'est pas simplement
une démarche intellectuel pour que la
confrontation
avec ce que on préférait ne pas voir se
produise, qu'on le veuille ou pas,
ces changements, ces défis à la
conscience. Et mon rôle en fait est de
fournir un langage qui aide les gens à
changer les normes, à renverser les
normes, à renverser ce qui est
conventionnel, ce qui est le passé.
Parce que être coincé dans le passé ou
utiliser le langage du passé fait partie
du problème.
le je comprends bien que les
intellectuels doivent fournir le
la mallette à outil de compréhension de
du langage, mais quand en face on a une
classe politique, une classe de cabinet
de communication qui prennent le
contrôle de la dialectique
et que on se rend compte que
l'apauvrissement culturel,
l'apauvrissement de la maîtrise de la
langue, que ce soit la langue anglaise
que la langue française, est-ce que
c'est je vais je vais être encore dur.
Est-ce que c'est pas du wishful thinking
de IPI et et qui et que vous êtes dans
votre propre bulle et vous vous rendez
pas compte que il y a une masse informe
de gens qui ont la tête dans le guidon
dans leur problème et que l'inertie de
cette masse informe nous emmène vers le
mur.
Je suis d'accord jusqu'à un certain
point.
Dans le langage dans lequel moi
j'évolue, on parle d'écoparalysie,
une forme d'inertie.
On est coincé dans un système, enfermé
dans un système que l'on ne pense pas
pouvoir changer à notre niveau. Changer
les ampoules d'éclairage, c'est pas
suffisant.
C'est aussi
psychologique, psychiatrique.
Nos problèmes affectent aussi notre
capacité
à voir clairement
et à faire cette transition
qui nous amènerait à une meilleure
qualité de vie pour nous-même. Donc je
suis tout à fait conscient de ces
problèmes. Donc il faut que je revienne
à un point où pourquoi faudrait-il
changer
un point c'est parce que comme je le
prétends
les
négatifs
attirent un positif. Plus on va vers le
négatif on se rend compte que on a
quitté notre vie d'espèce humaine vers
une vie qui ne l'est plus.
Le plus on nie notre nos positions, nos
émotions positives, plus elles acquent
de la valeur. On prend pour acquis
que on avait pas besoin de nommer
certaines choses parce que ça n'était
pas pertinent, on avait même pas y
pensé, les étaient données. Maintenant,
il y a des gens qui réfléchissent
à
faire par exemple quels sont les
derniers endroits du monde
qui sont intacts. Le tourisme devient la
cause de du désastre à venir, désastre
écologique à venir.
Je comprends parfaitement comment nous
sommes enfermés dans ce système. La
terre elle-même nous dit que
nous sommes en train de transgresser
d'une façon qui est autodestructrice.
Je ne souhaite pas
personnaliser la terre. Je ne veux pas
parler de GA en tant que la terre
devient une personne qui est son sa
propre agence. être animiste.
Je suis trop matérialiste, trop réaliste
pour aller aussi loin.
Mais quand votre pays commence à brûler
concrètement,
c'est plus le moment de réfléchir à
est-ce qu'on peut changer ou pas parce
que c'est votre maison est en feu. Ça a
un tel impact tellement grave.
Si vous êtes inouite et que vous vivez
dans l'Arctique, vous voyez que la glace
disparaît.
Si vous vivez en Floride, votre garage
se remplit d'eau et il y a un poulpe qui
il vit. C'est ce qui se produit. Dans
d'autres parties du monde,
la les preuves sont devant vous, comme
on dit en Australie, c'est plus de la
théorie.
Vous êtes assez heureux en France parce
que ce qui vous arrive c'est que
différents vignobles ne croisent pas
aussi bien ou il faut que vous importiez
des CPS de pays plus chauds pour les
replanter ici. Mais c'est pas une
tragédie de proportion mondiale mais
c'est le début d'un processus
où vous voyez des changements lentement
qui se produisent. Ça se produit
lentement. Donc les gens l'ignorent,
c'est comme un empoisonnement lent quand
le changement est rapide et dramatique
et fait peur. Alors là vraiment là ça
fait peur aux gens, ça les fait peur
jusqu'aux os.
C'est un poison rapide et ça génère des
réactions extrêmement différentes.
Et pour en revenir au cas d'étude de
l'Australie,
dans le dénior
debout, rien n'était important à la
place autre que la bière, le football,
le barbecue.
Il y en a beaucoup de ces bonnes choses
en Australie, mais récemment, j'ai lu
que parce qu'il faisait tellement chaud
et que la sécheresse était tellement
dure et que les feux ont été tellement
importants, on ne peut plus avoir de
barbecue. Donc, il y a plus de barbecue
australien.
C'est annulé parce que il est interdit
de faire du feu dans la nouvelle galle
du Sud.
C'est vraiment un réveil matin très dur.
Ça veut dire que les activités
quotidiennes doivent être changées.
C'est comme le coronavirus qui arrive
chez vous et qui vous ferme votre
plaisir du dimanche. Vous ne pouvez plus
partager cette expérience parce que le
risque de mettre le feu à la maison de
votre voisin ou au broussaill autour de
vous est trop grand.
Donc soudain, c'est l'imposition d'une
réalité que la plupart d'entre vous ne
souhaitait pas voir ou savoir. On
voudrait l'éviter. Les Australiens ont
été excellents dans ce domaine, aussi
bon que les Français, je pense.
On est dans la ligue
et en haut de la ligue pour ignorer les
choses. Mais quand ça vous frappe très
fort, on ne peut plus continuer à
l'ignorer.
et
ça va vous affecter, ça va affecter
votre mental, la façon dont vous relier
à tout le reste.
Ce changement sera affectera tout.
Vous savez en France quand on prend
conscience des choses, on a une une
technique qui est ancestrale.
On coupe des têtes.
Est-ce que vous pensez qu'on va revenir
à un écho, est-ce qu'on va en arriver à
un échoterrorisme ?
Je suis pacifiste IPI des années 60 et
70.
Je suis en faveur
d'une approche à la Gandie pour le
changement, mais j'accepte aussi le fait
que les êtres humains sont de façon
inhérente violente.
J'appelle la terra les terraftoras. Ce
sont les destructeurs de la terre. Ce
sont des sentiments qui vivent chez
nous. Ça fait partie de notre mental.
J'essaie de m'en occuper en disant que
le il faut laisser sortir nos émotions.
Les terrains naissants,
les les terraftoras, ce sont ceux qui
détruisent. Les terrains naissants sont
ceux qui créent.
Il doit y avoir il y aura une certains
conflit et la meilleure façon de s'en
occuper, c'est regarder
comment
les conflits entre les signes noirs se
résolvent entre signes blanc et signes
noir. Ils sont dans l'image l'un de
l'autre. Ils se battent contre leur
image.
Ce n'est pas quelque chose qui semble se
faire. C'est une image synchronisée l'un
de l'autre.
Et soudain, ça s'arrête et l'un des
signes s'en va, s'enfuit.
C'est une forme d'intimidation,
une guerre par intimidation. Et je me
rends compte que j'appelle cela dans le
livre
le besoin de muscles verts. On a besoin
de gens fort qui ne soi pas intimidé par
des fascistes.
Sinon,
il ne faut pas être
aperé par la nouvelle droite qui utilise
ce genre de d'activité pour faire
advenir leur changement. Mais prétendre
que ce genre de gens n'existe pas, c'est
être vraiment naïf. Il faut confronter
ce qui se faire face à ce qui se passe
avec nos forces
proportionnelles à l'opposition à
laquelle on veut faire face. Je suis
conscient aussi
du
Vous voulez que j'arrête pour un instant
?
Non non non. OK. On a juste une lampe
qui a qui s'est éteint mais ça va, on va
on va on va on va on va gérer.
Et bien que la lumière soit.
Donc ça ça tombe bien, je vais pouvoir
vous couper.
Est-ce que vous connaissez la
psychologie des foules de Gustave Lebon
? Est-ce que vous avez étudié la
psychologie des foules ? Et est-ce que
pas par le bon mais j'ai étudié quelques
aspects de la physiologie, la
psychologie des foules. C'est une
littérature qui doit être aussi qui doit
exister en anglais.
Vous savez ce que dit Gustave Lebon sur
la psychologie des foules ?
Non,
on vous le conseille chaleureusement. Je
vais vous poser une autre question.
Est-ce que vous savez ce que ça veut
dire homo omini loupous est ?
L'homme est un loup pour l'homme.
Est-ce que ça suggère que les êtres
humains sont comme des loup
qui se soutiendraient ou ne se
soutiendraient pas ? Je ne suis pas
certain du sens de cette phrase. La vie
sociale des loups est très intéressante.
Est-ce que vous connaissez les black ?
Non. que sur
Est-ce que vous avez déjà vu que sur
certaines manifestations de temps en
temps, il y avait des gens plus
déterminés pour aller au contact avec
les forces de l'ordre ?
Oui, ça je l'ai vu.
En France, on les appelle les black
block. Je pense qu'en Australie, on doit
aussi les appeler les black block.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ça ? Est-ce
que c'est
Non, je pense pas qu'on les appelle
comme ça en Australie.
Ils sont là mais ils sont pas appelés
comme ça.
OK. On espère qu'ils aient la même
fibre. Eh euh
oui, absolument, ils ont la même fibre.
Est-ce que vous cautionnez ça ? Est-ce
que vous trouvez ça normal que il y a
des gens qui décident de prendre
d'autres voix pour se faire entendre ?
Je pense que c'est bon d'intimider les
autres de la façon dont eux tentent de
nous intimider. Mais si ça passe dans la
violence
qui nécessite des armes, des arme à feu,
alors à ce moment-là, ça fait partie du
même problème que ce que nous essayons
de résoudre.
Ça sera l'anilation de l'âme des
humains, une violence contre une autre
violence.
Je ne dis pas ça parce que je suis
pacifiste simplement, mais parce que la
seule façon dont on va arriver à un
véritable changement,
c'est comme je le dis,
j'ai vu
à quel point des situations violentes
peuvent être résolues
dans les sociétés traditionnelles
d'êtres humains.
Je peux le voir avec les signes noirs.
Ça veut dire qu'on peut l'essayer.
Des gens forts, des hommes et des femmes
forts
avec un autre ordre du jour.
Vous savez, ils vont dans les gymnases
et euh se font des muscles, mais ça ne
produit pas beaucoup d'électricité tout
ça. Donc, il y a d'autres façons d'agir.
J'ai toujours été conscient du fait que
la mort euh de l'écologie
assassiné par ceux qui veulent arrêter
leur activité.
Et j'entretiens l'idée dans le livre que
là où les écolos sont tués par ceux qui
souhaitent continuer
à tuer des rhinocéros pour leurs cornes
par exemple.
C'est là où il faut prendre des armes
effectivement contre ces gens-là et les
éliminer. Mais
où est la ligne entre l'intimidation et
euh lutter contre la violence ? C'est
très difficile à dire.
Mais là où les gens sont assassinés, je
ne pense pas qu'il y ait lieu de mettre
simplement un peu de muscle vert et de
les intimider. Non, je suis réaliste sur
l'étendue de la violence qui est dirigée
contre ceux qui sont terraissants
ou sont qui sont créateurs
de vie. Je ne prétends pas dans le livre
que c'est une solution facile à trouver,
mais l'alternative est quelque chose que
je vois clairement, c'est pas d'avenir.
Quel regard vous portez sur les
institutions internationales quand on
voit l'échec des accords de Paris,
l'échec de Kyoto, l'échec de la COP 21.
Est-ce qu'il faut qu'on fasse sans la
caste politique ? arrêter d'attendre
cette ces commandements venant d'en
haut. Est-ce que c'est à l'échelle
locale qu'il faut s'organiser ?
À tous les niveaux,
dans tous les lieux, il y a pas un
niveau qui va exclusivement des autres
changer la situation.
Mais vous avez raison,
dans le leadership politique actuel,
il n'y a personne qui soit dans une
situation de gouverner
de telle sorte que ce changement
advienne.
En Australie, nos politiciens sont
gouvernés. Ils ne sont pas ceux qui
gouvernent.
Donc euh
ce
il vous savez ces gens-là donnent des
grandes
des fonds énormes aux partis politiques
et
d'autres organisations qui assurent ce
cercle d'influence entre les
politiciens,
les industries, les lobbyistes.
Ils sont tous interchangeables.
C'est pas des systèmes différents.
C'est un processus systématique
qui ferme le cercle du pouvoir
de telle sorte que la démocratie dans sa
forme la plus pure soit exclu.
Peu important que les gens votent
aujourd'hui, il y a plus de différence
entre les principaux partis politiques.
Je suggère effectivement que la
démocratie
est anthropocentrique
par définition s'occupe de problèmes
pertinents pour les êtres humains. Mais
nous avons des sujets à régler avec le
climat, à éviter l'extinction des
espèces. La démocratie doit être
élargie. au-delà du démo
et moi je suis en fa faire de la somme
biocratie c'estàd une forme de
gouvernance pour tous les êtres vivants
et pas simplement les humains.
Mais bon
c'est une tentative nouvelle.
Je ne pense pas que la symbiocratie
prévale demain, mais si des gens
commencent à
s'interroger sur la validité du Demos,
pourquoi est-ce que nous acceptons cette
forme de gouvernance que nous avons
actuellement ?
Le gouvernement du peuple par le peuple,
pour le peuple comme la seule chose qui
soit importante sur terre. Non,
c'est plein du
arrogance et de la dominance et du
l'autoritarisme qu'on avait par le
passé. Je souhaite que les gens
réfléchissent différemment et c'est le
but de mes nouveaux mots, de mon nouveau
langage.
Je pense que nous sommes par vous savez,
moi j'étais professeur de durabilité et
les gens me disent "Mais qu'est-ce qui
va pas avec la durabilité ? C'est un
beau concept. Oui, ça l'était. Mais
maintenant, qui est-ce qu'on a pris
possession ? Et bien, c'est la classe
industrielle qui en a pris possession
pour justifier de sa propre existence.
Tout devient durable.
C'est comme résilience.
C'était
des gentils universitaires à Stockholm
qui avaient mis cela en avant.
C'est très une bonne direction vers
laquelle aller pour les êtres humains.
Je ne dirai pas qu'il faut pas être
résilient, mais Trump, Donald Trump
utilise le mot résilience aujourd'hui
pour éviter de s'occuper des causes du
changement climatique. Le gouvernement
australien utilise le mot résilience
parce que c'est un chouette mot parce
que c'est bien utilisé.
environmental transition
un autre mot oui. Transition transition
vers quoi ? Ça a aucun sens. Donc on est
plein de ces choseslà.
Quand j'enseignais, j'ai essayé que mes
étudiants voient la différence entre la
véritable résilience et la résilience
pervertie.
La résilience pervertie, c'est la
résilience des choses qui devraient être
éliminé. C'est comme les mauvaises
odeurs, elles restent là, on peut pas
s'en débarrasser. Et donc la résilience
devient quelque chose de négatif, une
condition négative lorsque les choses
sont indésirables
et deviennent apparemment impossible à
éliminer.
Je commence à voir le rôle de la langue
comme joue un rôle extrêmement important
dans l'anilation du système actuel. Et
si vous êtes intéressé par le potentiel
et la possibilité du changement,
non seulement il faut l'attaquer par la
science et par l'idéologie politique qui
est une autre possibilité
exploré par d'autres gens que moi
beaucoup plus en détail. Mais si on
utilise le langage pour
exposer, faire exploser ces échecs pour
avoir
de nouvelles émotions,
c'est comme dans le film le magicien de
ose tire le rideau et puis le grand le
grand sorcier de c'est un pauvre petit
bonhomme, un pauvre petit magicien qui
prétend être puissant mais il y a rien
en fait.
Si si je vous dis on ne peut pas
ressentir
ce que l'on peut ce que l'on ne peut pas
verbaliser.
Est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ça ?
Je crois qu'il y a beaucoup de vérités
là-dedans.
Des sentiments
qui sont importants
qu'on n' pas réussi à articuler.
Ce commentaire devrait être mené plus
loin.
J'écris au sujet de l'extinction des
émotions.
Nous vivons dans une culture
qui a enlevé nos capacités d'avoir des
engagements émotionnels avec ce qui est
important. C'est une forme de
d'hygiénisation.
Il y a un terme pour cela. On réduit le
monde
à une sorte de poupée
inodore et insipide.
Si on peut extendre le langage
vers des choses mauvaises, on peut le
diriger aussi vers des choses bodes pour
stimuler les bons les bonnes émotions.
Voilà ce qui est fait par les gens qui
sont créatifs,
les terrains naissants. Et c'est ainsi
que mon travail aura un effet plus
important.
Moi, je suis en mission si vous voulez
pour créer la terminologie, le cadre
conceptuel, les mots nécessaires pour
décrire le nouveau monde vers lequel
nous souhaitons aller.
[Musique]
Bien entendu, de créer les de les créer
eux-mêmes.
Je vois mon rôle comme subversif.
Dire pourquoi faut-il accepter le
langage des spin doctors et des
politicards ? Non seulement c'est
ennuyeux mais il faut on n'est pas
obligé d'écouter un robot.
Ils ont des programmes pour quelle que
soit la question qu'on leur pose. Ils
auront toujours les mêmes réponses. Nous
sommes à une époque aujourd'hui où les
gens en sont fatigués.
Et on peut voir que c'est une forme de
fausseté qui est évidente aujourd'hui.
Les gens ne font même plus semblant de
dire la vérité.
Je vous ouvre une parenthèse.
Avant que le direct commence, on a on a
discuté un petit peu de votre voyage en
Allemagne et vous m'avez dit que c'était
beaucoup plus facile de rentrer en
France.
On vous a pas posé de questions mais
quand vous êtes rentré en Allemagne là,
vous êtes fait attraper par la douane et
ils vous ont poser beaucoup de
questions.
Pourquoi votre avis vous ont posé des
questions ? Just few.
Si j'allais aux États-Unis, je pense
qu'il y aurait beaucoup plus de
questions qui seraient poser.
Ils vous feront ils vous mettront
peut-être un petit toucher rectal au
passage.
Je dois dire que ça m'est arrivé par le
passé. J'étais au Canada
au moment de l'attaque contre les tours
jumelles, les Twin Towers. J'ai pris un
rendez-vous pour voir un universitaire
que je respecte beaucoup, Mary Boton, un
écoanarchiste qui vivait dans le
Vermont. Et pour passer du Canada aux
États-Unis, ça impliquait,
comment dirais-je ? Un profilage racial.
Euh moi, je suis bon un blanc.
Les gens ne croyaient pas que j'étais
lié à une université et j'ai dû passer
par tout le processus et les convaincre
que j'étais de bonne foi
comme ma femme puis mes enfants ont
plaisanté.
Heureusement que j'avais une bonne
famille blanche. Sans ça, il m'aurait
tenu et retenu pendant très longtemps.
Ce processus d'être profilé
m'est arrivé à plusieurs reprises. Je
comprends ce qui se passe.
J'étais arrêté parce que j'étais un
terroriste moluquois
au Pays-Bas dans les années 70. Donc
j'ai vraiment une longue histoire de
profilage
qui rendait ma vie inconfortable.
Est-ce que vous avez été arrêté en
Allemagne pour vous poser des questions
? Parce que l'Allemagne produit du
charbon, exploite du charbon. Est-ce
qu'ils ont fait le parallèle entre l'OPI
terroriste australien qui vient
peut-être armer les consciences et les
esprits en Allemagne ? Est-ce que
c'était une démarche dissuasive
d'intimidation ?
Non, j'aurais bien aimé être aussi
célèbre que cela.
Non, c'est pas le cas. Les Allemands
sont que un seul doigt, pas deux. C'est
ça.
Juste un doigt. Oui,
j'ai pensé que ma venue était pacifique
par rapport à mes tentatives de rentrer
dans les États-Unis et même pour rentrer
en Australie.
Vous devez passer par des processus
bureaucratiques plus que dans tout autre
pays.
Donc je ne peux pas
blâmer les Allemands pour demander
m'avoir demandé pourquoi j'allais en
Allemagne. Même si vous entrez dans un
pays de l'Union européenne,
[Musique]
c'est comme si vous entriez dans tous
les pays de l'Union européenne. Je ne
connais pas la bureaucratie
de l'Union européenne. Pas du tout. Tout
ce que je sais, c'est que
les Britanniques ont voulu en sortir,
ils l'ont réussi.
Donc ça sera difficile pour eux de
rentrer en Europe. Ils devront passer
par les mêmes questionnements. Pourquoi
voulez-vous venir ? Que faites-vous ? Où
allez-vous résider ?
C'est vraiment
la fin de cette possibilité de voyager à
l'international tel qu'on l'a connu
précédemment.
C'est une des conséquences
de la destruction des tours jumelles et
du terrorisme. Ça a eu un impact sur le
monde mais c'est un problème différent.
Je vous ouvre une parenthèse, je vous
coupe.
OK. Imaginez qu'un groupe terroriste
avait euh brûlé autant d'hectares de
forêt en Australie, avait tué autant de
koala et de kangourous, avait euh mis un
bordel tellement monstrueux. Euh est-ce
que on serait déjà en guerre contre eux
? On aurait déployé les avions, les
portesavion, les systèmes de
renseignement, tout ça, tout ça.
Ça vous fait pas bizarre que
il y ait cette détresse environnementale
et que le mouvement va en guerre contre
cette menace
soit vraiment rachidique
par rapport à la réponse hypothétique
qu'ils auraient déployé contre un
mouvement terroriste.
un peu tangentiel mais le gouvernement
australien a tenté de faire porter le
chapeau au mouvement extrémiste
écologique australien parce que les
mouvements écologiques australiens
euh
avait mis la pression sur
les personnes qui s'occupent des forêts.
le l'administration des forêts en
Australie, ce sont les écologistes qui
ont
en fait interdit les brûl. Et donc cette
guerre idéologique a eu lieu quelques
heures
dès que les feux ont affecté les
l'Australie. C'était une bagarre
idéologique, une guerre idéologique qui
n'a pas cessé, elle continue.
Ça ne me surprend pas que la classe
dominante dirigeante le fasse parce que
évidemment ça évite que la faute leur
soit attribuée.
ont fait glisser la réalité des
problèmes et ça permet aux dirigeants de
partir en vacances pendant les feux. Les
dirigeants ont quitté le pays,
un pays en feu. Donc il y a une colère.
En même temps qu'il y a une nouvelle
conscience
qui se génère quand le public
perd la foi dans la classe politique,
perd confiance dans la voie politique,
pas simplement pour qu'ils aient une
position décente, mais sur les positions
qui sont les leurs.
Ils ont lutté
pour maintenir la démocratie
parlementaire.
Est-ce que
est-ce que est-ce que vous avez essayé
de les comprendre avec un autre prisme
de lecture, les comprendre la classe
politique ? Est-ce que vous avez essayé
de comprendre que pour eux à court terme
la menace économique est beaucoup plus
dévastatrice et délétaire que la menace
écologique ? C'est-à-dire qu' ils font
une politique symptomatique parce que le
danger d'un déraillement, d'une
défaillance
du système économique, si on dit voilà
maintenant vous allez arrêter d'épuiser
le biotope parce que c'est plus
possible, les les systèmes financiers
vont faire la tête
et donc la menace de déstabilisation
du système économique pour eux est
peut-être 1000 fois plus importante que
un milliard de kangourous cramés.
Vous avez raison dans ce diagnostic,
c'est exactement ce qui se passe.
On pourrait l'appeler du court termisme.
Ça va réussir pendant un certain temps.
Mais comme pour le magicien de OSE,
la nature fausse de cette réponse sera
démontrée.
Et je dirais que
le système économique
soutend
ce qui se faisait déjà dans les années
70 avec ce concept d'économie stable. Il
y a rien de nouveau
et c'est pas quelque chose pour lequel
je prends
crédit, mais c'est vous savez c'est le
principe de la thermodynamique.
On peut pas avoir un système de
développement continu et quand on pousse
cette idée trop loin en disant "Oui, on
peut faire ce qu'on veut, on peut
continuer euh ainsi, on va on va on va
rentrer dans le mur." Et on a on est
déjà rentré dans le mur en Australie.
Est-ce qu'on est rentré dans le mur
suffisamment violemment ? Je ne sais
pas. C'est de la politique qui se
produit en temps réel. Maintenant,
j'ai j'ai quelques questions d'un ami
qui s'appelle Pablo Serv qui me les a
envoyé. Je vais je vais vous en poser
deux trois. La première, c'est
sommes-nous prêts émotionnellement
à affronter le 21e siècle ?
pour affronter le 21e siècle.
Ma réponse c'est que nous ne sommes pas
prêts émotionnellement parce qu'on n'
pas la langue le langage pertinent, les
concepts pertinents, la critique
pertinente
de
langage
qu'on a essayé par le passé pour
s'occuper de ces problèmes ne sert à
rien. Je ne dis pas que je suis la seule
personne qui tente de se mesurer à ses
problèmes à travers un objectif
émotionnel, mais je suis heureux de voir
que je suis un pionnier dans ce domaine
et je voudrais que cette approche soit
suivie par beaucoup plus de gens pour
qu'on puisse voir le rôle des émotions,
la centralité du rôle des émotions au
21e siècle et par quelque chose qui
devrait être ignoré ou quelque chose de
marginal.
Parce que au 19e siècle, quelqu'un nous
a dit que les émotions n'étaient pas une
expérience humaine valable et devrait
être exclue de la prise de décision ou
exclu du royaume de euh
du savoir et laissé dans au domaine de
l'intuition. Je dis que la bonne science
et les bonnes émotions doivent
travailler ensemble pour donner une
bonne société. Et je dirais que
la récupération des bonnes émotions
est absolument fondamental pour le 21e
siècle.
Et si on ne le fait pas,
l'extinction de nos émotions
sera le début de quelque chose et nous
serons incapables de résister aux forces
que vous avez mentionnées.
réactions seront
éliminées par des forces qui sont
tellement grandes qu'elles anticipent
toute action que nous pourrions faire et
le commercialiserait
et nous rendrait inerte.
Of barbarie.
Oui,
j'aimerais connaître mieux la barbarie.
Je ne l'ai pas étudié mais je crois
savoir de quoi on parle. J'ai une autre
question pour vous toujours de Pablo.
Est-ce qu'on se remet de la sol
nostalgie
ou est-ce que ça va durer toute la vie ?
La réponse
c'est oui.
La solostalgie est une condition, un
état qui peut être inversé.
l'idée que
c'est enfermé dans des endroits dont on
peut fuir
et comme Sterlingologue l'a dit,
c'est tellement profond,
c'est une situation débilitante, on
sortira jamais.
C'est comme la nostalgie, ça peut vous
tuer.
Non non, j'ai pas entendu parler.
L'homme qui s'est immolé.
Ah
la réponse
extrême et tragique
d'un point de vue humain. Mais je crois
qu'il est possible
de s'occuper des causes de la solalgie.
Je l'ai mentionné précédemment, la
restauration, la réparation, une des
choses que l'on peut faire pour y aider.
lutter contre le système qui le cause.
J'étais impliqué dans des communautés ou
des groupes
qui ont mené Rio Tinto devant les
tribunaux
devant les tribunaux de Nouvelle-Ger du
Sud pour comprendre les les implications
et les effets du bruit de la poussière
sur l'environnement. la perte de
biodiversité, la solastalgie,
c'était un état négatif que les gens se
ressentit, qui leur été imposé et qui
n'était pas justifiable, même en terre
des bénéfices économiques, on en tirait
que cette mine de charbon apporterait
aux gens.
Et le gouvernement a
changé la législation pour annuler le
résultat,
la la décision de la cour.
Et donc nous avons perdu. Mais ça montre
que la lutte peut se faire à différents
niveaux
et au moins, il y a eu
une décision de justice où une mine de
charbon
n'a pas été autorisée et l'inclusion de
la seule nostalgie
qui était incluse. Donc cette notion
incluse dans le jugement, la seule
stalgie ne pouvait pas être imposée par
une mine de charbon.
Et donc l'ouverture de cette mine a été
refusée. Ma réponse à cette question
c'est que on peut défier les force qui
crée la solalgie.
On peut s'engager
dans une forme de réforme
qui soit la réforme de l'environnement
biophysique qui est endommagé.
une réforme des processus politiques
économiques qui crée ces dommages et
dans ce processus vous êtes capable de
réformer et réparer vos dommages
psychologiques. La seule nostalgie
peut-être allégée et enlevée.
Une autre question. Que pensez-vous de
la théorie des cinq stades de la fin de
vie de Kubler Rose et autres théories du
deuil ? Est-ce que ça peut aider à
traverser cette tempête ?
Question extrêmement complexe et la
réponse doit être complexe aussi.
Je vois le deuil
comme une réaction
à notre besoin de comprendre la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes.
Le deuil techniquement, comme je le
comprends en anglais, est un sentiment
qui vient lorsque l'on perd le contact
avec quelqu'un de vivant qui meurt et
nos relations intimes doivent cesser
avec cette personne. Le 5è état de CL
Ross, c'est l'acceptation si on y
arrive. Et je pense que c'est la
situation la plus désastreuse que l'on
peut avoir dans notre situation. Il ne
faut pas accepter le deuil. Il faut se
rebeller contre le deuil. Il faut
les gens parlent de différents types de
deuil. On dit écho deuil par exemple.
Voilà. On a fait avec le deuil, tout ce
qu'on pouvait faire avec le deuil
comme d'autres émotions humaines.
Et bien que j'apprécie et que je
comprends la logique pour se faire,
je préférerais
que on fasse on prenne plus soin du
langage émotionnel que nous utilisons.
Le climat ne meurt pas. Même s'il est
endommagé, il est toujours là.
Nous ne pouvons pas détruire
l'environnement tel qu'on le comprend.
On peut le changer d'une façon qu'on
n'aime pas, mais c'est pas quelque chose
qui est présent dans notre vie.
On peut penser que l'on peut éteindre
toute vie sur la planète, mais en fait
il y a des bactéries qui aiment vivre
près des volcans sous-marins. Il y en a
d'autres qui l'aiment encore plus chaud
son environnement.
Ce sont des bactéries qui adorent
l'hyperchaleur. C'est une forme
d'arrogance de penser que l'on peut
détruire ou éteindre complètement les
choses
euh qui qui font partie de ce grand
grave problème.
Faire le deuil, il faut faire le deuil
de choses que nous avons définitivement
perdues. Mais même là, je pense que la
culture humaine
et le concept de deuil a une pertinence
dans toutes les cultures humaines
et il y a des façons de le comprendre et
d'exprimer notre deuil. Parfois, il faut
prendre des idées
de notre culture, de la mettre dans un
autre contexte. Donc, je suis en faveur
de cela. Je donne un exemple dans le
livre des inuites
de l'Aric
qui ont l'expérience
d'un changement rapide et négatif
de des glaces. La tristesse.
C'était difficile pour eux de comprendre
cela.
Leur façon de le faire, c'est qu'ils ont
pris un mot de leur culture qui était
qui signifie un ami qui agit de façon
bizarre.
On va avec un au bar avec un copain qui
boit un coup de trop qui commence à vous
balancer des coups de point. C'est
dérangeant. Votre ami agit d'une façon
imprévisible. Il n'avait pas de mots
pour la façon dont le climat agissait.
Mais c'était semblable à analogique par
exemple à la façon dont cétait amis euh
se comportait mal. Donc ils ont détruit
décrit le climat qui devenait ogok.
C'est une indication que toutes les
cultures luttent pour trouver la
terminologie, les mots pour décrire ce
changement profond qui a lieu. Nous
sommes à une étape où nous luttons pour
trouver les bons mots pour décrire
le les tempêtes émotionnelles dans
lesquelles nous sommes. Ma tâche, mon
travail a été de tenter d'être plus
précis
plus que de mettre égo devant ou écho
devant d'œil écho d'œuil. Non, j'ai des
problèmes pas simplement avec
l'application du terme deuil maischo.
Echo vient de Oos qui signifie en grec
la gestion de la maisonnée, la
gouvernance de la maison.
Et je n'aime pas particulièrement un mot
qui a des implications de domination
humaine et de gouvernance qui soit
appliqué à la situation dans laquelle
nous sommes actuellement où la
domination humaine et la gouvernance ont
causé les problèmes qui nous donnent ici
du deuil.
C'est pas une insulte aux peuples
indigènes qui ont une relation plus
intime avec le reste de la vie.
qui sont décrits dans les confins de
l'icos.
Donc il y a un problème là
d'une appropriation culturelle. Dans un
sens, on utilise des systèmes ou des
biosciences pour décrire toutes leurs
expériences en relation avec le reste du
monde.
C'est pas très productif. Et l'autre
oosse, l'économie, la gestion de
l'économie.
Nous parlons du capital naturel,
de biodiversité,
toutes ces choses où nous tentons de
dire
si nous sommes des bons capitalistes,
nous verrons comment on peut verdir le
capitalisme. Locos devient vert et nous
vivrons heureux pour toujours. C'est une
situation extrêmement dangereuse à
adopter, mais bon, je comprends ce que
vous dites. Euh, désolé de de faire des
choses euh que les gens ne voient pas,
mais on s'est bien compris. J'ai une
question d'internet qui est très courte
mais qui est qui est lourde de
signification. Une question de Louis
Jacques. Que pensent-il des problèmes
liés au réfugiés climatiques ?
C'est un problème excessivement
compliqué.
J'y pense de différentes manières. L'une
d'entre elles, c'est
nous voyons déjà un monde
profondément
altéré
par le changement global dans
le climat qui force les gens à émigrer
d'un endroit à l'autre.
La montée des eaux va changer cela
dramatiquement. Les réfugiés climatiques
à l'avenir seront se compterant par
million si ce n'est par milliards et ça
affectera tous les continents, toutes
les îles. C'est pas comme si simplement
quelqu'un allait souffrir de cela et
d'autres
l'éviteraient.
L'idée
que l'on peut le surmonter facilement,
ça c'est de l'utopie.
Ça va créer des graves problèmes à
l'humanité.
J'en parle dans mon livre en disant que
on a besoin
une culture hybride urgente qui accepte
un peu du passé et
l'importance de la géographie.
La Terre n'est pas uniforme. Elle génère
des réactions différentes divers
endroits.
Les gens d'un autre endroit viennent,
ils sont forcés de quitter leur maison,
leur terre, leur espace. Ils doivent
s'ajuster
aux façons de vivre de ceux qui les
accueillent.
Et ceux qui les accueillent sont déjà
cette expérience d'homogénéisation du
monde, la colonisation d'autres espèces
de tous les autres endroits. Donc cette
idée d'un espace pur qui doit être
protégé doit être abandonné. Et dans le
même temps, l'idée que les migrants
viennent simplement avec leur vision du
monde et leur relation à
l'environnement, à l'agriculture et à
d'autres choses sans être influencé par
leurs hôtes,
que ce soit le changement climatique ou
des raisons différentes,
nous sommes dans un espace qui exige
cette réaction créative.
Et c'est ni la gauche ni la droite, ce
n'est pas lié au passé. C'est un avenir
qui doit être construit. Et bien sûr,
c'est trop facile de dire que il faut le
faire.
Quels sont les aspects techniques ?
Et j'ai mets un message :
"Venez aider. et je me bats contre je me
bats avec ces idées très complexes. On a
besoin de plus de gens qui réfléchissent
à ça.
J'ai j'ai une autre question d'internet
que je vais essayer de de reformuler, de
ne pas dénaturer. Est-ce que vous pensez
pas que d'avoir inventé le mot
solastalgie,
ce n'est pas une façon de psychiatriser
les gens qui parlent de la collapsologie
et donc de le discréditer ?
C'est une critique de mon travail.
Disons que c'est la construction sociale
de la réalité
ou l'invention
d'une nouvelle maladie mentale
dont on pourrait s'occuper en la
médicalisant ou la médicant.
C'est loin de ma pensée lorsque j'ai
créé ce concept.
Mais
vous savez, j'accepte
que d'autres personnes l'interprètent
différemment de ce que moi j'ai pensé
comme en littérature ou en art
d'ailleurs. Et je dois être plus
attentif à la façon faire plus attention
la façon dont j'exprime les choses parce
que parfois des mauvaises
interprétations peuvent se produire.
Mais moi, je le décrirai comme
prenant des risques en créant ce concept
de solalgie.
Et peut-être que je ne me suis pas
exprimé suffisamment clairement en
utilisant un mot comme maladie
qui mènerait les gens à penser que je
médicalise certains problèmes ou que je
crée un problème psychologique là où il
s'agit d'une fabrication.
Les concepts, vous savez passent au test
non pas à l'université.
de façon très rigoureuse, mais aussi pas
seulement à l'université, mais à la
façon dont les gens réagissent au mot.
Si c'est accepté, s'il est accepté
grandement dans une variété de concepts
et de contexte, ça signifie que ça a une
capacité
à engager les gens.
J'ai même eu des gens, des aborigènes
d'Australiens qui sont venus me voir et
qui m'ont dit qu'ils approuvaient ce
concept parce que ça n'écrivait quelque
chose qui leur arrive et que leur propre
langue n'arrivaient pas à exprimer.
Ça revient auatok à cette histoire.
Toutes les cultures luttent avec cette
histoire de changement global rapide. Et
c'est pour ça que le titre du livre,
c'est nouveaux mots pour un nouveau
monde. Je j'y crois. Nous luttons pour
articuler les choses dont on parle
actuellement parce que notre langue a
été appauvrie en ce qui concerne ces
problèmes là. Apauvri parce queon n'a
pas eu à s'en occuper par le passé. Ça
ne fait pas partie de notre expérience
de l'évolution comme
espèce mondialisée.
J'ai une autre question de la
communauté. Je vais vous la poser en
anglais avec mon plus bel accent parce
qu'ils l'ont posé en anglais. Ils ont
fait l'effort de la poser en anglais.
language
of
authoritary
arbitary laws ofysics
word against anopo
accepting
some fairy tales
and relieved our
good consci
conscience
Est-ce que cela porte sur
Je suis pas très certain des lois de la
physique là.
Moi, je lutte l'entropie à chaque fois
que je la rencontre.
Je lutte contre l'entropie conceptuelle,
là où nos concepts sont perdus dans
une homogénéité
ennuyeuse
d'un univers insensé,
ce qui est le résultat final de la
deuxième loi de la thermodynamique.
Si je comprends bien la question,
comment est-ce que je réagis
personnellement
à cette rupture
de ce qui intéresse et vital de la vie
sur terre ? la destruction par ceux qui
tentent de le transformer
en tant que
mort de l'univers.
La vie est une stratégie qui s'oppose
à l'entrepie. Justement, je suis père,
grand-père,
il faut que je pense que la vie de façon
inhérente et bonne et que la mort c'est
ennuyeux.
Et du côté de la vie, c'est une bonne
lutte.
J'utilise mes capacités de
réflexion pour construire un avenir pour
l'humanité où la vie serait beaucoup
plus importante qu'elle ne l'
actuellement.
Dans cette ère dans laquelle nous
sommes, dans cette anthropocène,
je l'appelle l'opsène,
incapable de valoriser la vie.
au-delà
l'égocentrisme
et les privilégiés.
Si je vous dis heureux les simples
d'esprit aujourd'hui, j'ai compris.
J'ai essayé aussi
de
faire revivre notre spiritualité
avec
ce mot de guild gedaussira.
Je crois que les marchands de
spiritualité
classique sont passés de mode.
Je tente de laïiser ce que je trouve
extraordinaire au sujet de la vie
et je l'appelle le Gedist parce que le
GID
dans les vieux langages indo-européens
c'est
la racine des mots qui disent bon bien
ensemble.
C'est de là l'origine de ces termes dans
les anciennes préfixes indo-européens.
Je suis prêt à tenter quelque chose de
nouveau parce que j'ai vu l'échec du
passé à donner quelque chose de
pertinent pour le 21e siècle. Et donc je
ne le fais pas parce que j'aime inventer
des choses. Je le fais parce que j'aime
parce que je vois qu'il manque quelque
chose, un vide qui doit être rempli.
pour que nous êtres humains puissions
commencer une conversation utile et
bonne sur ce que ça signifie d'avoir une
vie spirituelle dans un monde laïque.
Peut-être que c'est dingue mais je
j'essaie de le faire.
Combien vous gagnez en tant que retraité
?
Zéro.
Ça me coûte de l'argent
de faire ce que je fais. Je ne gagne
rien.
Combien ? Non, non. Combien vous gagnez
avec votre pension de retraite ?
Et bien, j'ai je l'ai dépensé pour
acheter ma ferme et faire croître des
légumes. Je n'ai aucun investissement
personnel dans le marché boursier ou
dans un fond de pension.
Je suis un homme entretenu en quelque
sorte parce que ma femme a une retraite.
J'ai décidé que
je ne pouvais pas laisser mon argent
dans un système que je tente de
détruire. Mais heureusement, ma femme
n'est pas aussi folle que moi et donc
elle prend soin de moi.
On va parler de d'un Australien, du plus
français des Australiens, Julien
Assange.
Est-ce que Est-ce qu'on peut dire un mot
sur Julian Assange ?
Est-ce que c'est un mécanisme de défense
que vous utilisez là ?
Non. c'est que moi j'ai suivi Wikileak,
je comprends la position d'Assanji
mais pas simplement.
Je soutiens Wikileaks, je soutiens
la libération d'Assange
parce que il n'a commis aucun crime
contre la Suède ou les Suédois
et
son le traitement qui lui est infligé
est abominable. C'est une injustice.
Donc je soutiens
ceux qui aimeraient que
quelqu'un qui a tenté
de faire connaître la vérité au public
de telle sorte que les forces de
l'autorité tentaient d'éviter.
J'ai des inquiétudes
lorsque la diffusion de l'information
peut faire du mal à d'autres.
Je ne pense pas que ça a été le cas avec
Wikileak et l'information qui a été
révélée.
Donc ma position c'est que
c'est un Australien qui est citoyen du
monde qui souffre
et dans une injustice
qui se poursuit.
C'est quelque chose d'une des choses les
pires que j'ai vu dans la société
contemporaine.
On arrive à la fin de notre interview.
On a pour habitude de poser deux
dernières questions.
La première, c'est "Est-ce que vous avez
trois livres à conseiller à notre
communauté ?" Et la dernière c'est
"Est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour
les jeunes générations ?" Et
rappelez-moi comment s'appelle votre
livre.
Les émotions de la terre, de nouveaux
mots pour un nouveau monde. C'est un bon
livre.
J'aime bien que les gens le lisent.
Je ne dirais pas que c'est un des trois,
mais c'est très difficile comme
question. Je lis beaucoup et je suis
influencé par un très grand nombre de
gens.
Si je me rapproche
du domaine qui m'inspire, qui me donne
des choses à étudier, je lis Robert
Mcfallen
publié qui a publié un livre qui
s'appelle Underland,
les relations émotionnelles et mentales
au monde
quelque chose qui est souterrain
que les choses verraient comme ayant
un lien à mon propre travail.
En ce qui concerne la philosophie
environnementale,
je suis inspiré par
Alder Leopold
et laisser réfléchir comme une montagne.
Thinking mountain, ça a une résonance.
dans ma vie depuis le moment où je l'ai
lu très tôt et j'espère qu'il est
disponible en traduction en français.
J'espère que ça a été publié
depuis l'époque où il a été publié en
anglais dans les années 50.
Et
je ne suis pas quelqu'un qui écrit
beaucoup sur la nature. Moi, j'écris sur
les humains et sur les réactions
humaines.
Mais j'ai lu un livre
de AJ Biker, le pèlerin.
des observations de ces oiseaux.
Étant amoureux de des oiseaux et ayant
passer la plus grande partie de sa vie.
Moi en cherchant la compagnie des
oiseaux
et ayant partager le monde avec eux, je
recommanderai la lecture de du pèlerin
de Baker. Pas simplement parce que c'est
vraiment
une très belle écriture et en anglais,
j'ai trouvé
sa son écriture, sa capacité à décrire
et amener le lecteur
dans un monde qui n'existe peut-être
plus.
Dans l'Angleterre d'après-gerre,
le livre décrit
la vie du faucon pèlerin à travers les
yeux d'un observateur d'oiseaux.
Mais par beaucoup d'aspects, ça se relie
directement à mon travail. Ce livre se
relie à mon travail.
Bus tombe sur un oiseau mort
de couleur jaune et il s'inquiète
du fait que l'oiseau a pu être
empoisonné
et il va plus loin. Il parle
de la puanteur de l'argent qui
envahissait la vie des oiseaux
comme Solid Spring de Carson
qui considère le rôle des humains dans
ce qu'on appelle l'échide ou le
terracide, la destruction et
l'assassinat de la terre.
Il a écrit au sujet de quelque chose
qui est notre incapacité à faire
attention et à observer ce qui se
produit autour de nous,
ce qui reste du monde de la nature.
Il décrit un homme qui traverse
un pont, une digue
près de la mer. Il est complètement pris
par sa carte routière et sa carte
routière l'empêche de voir ce qu'il y a
autour de lui. Il y a des euh baleines
qui sont en train de migrer
et qui brillent dans le soleil, mais il
ne les voit pas.
Et je le vois ce passage comme semblable
au monde dans lequel on vit.
Je suis dans un taxi pour venir ici à
cette interview, à cette entrevue. Il y
a des gens qui sont tout à côté de la
tour Effel, mais tout ce qu'ils font
c'est qu'ils regardent leur téléphone
portable alors que
une des architectures les plus
merveilleuses au monde est à côté d'eux.
Ils ne la regardent pas. On le fait en
ville. Imaginez un peu ce que
ce qu'on fait
avec les oiseaux qui existent encore
dans la nature. Personne ne fait plus
attention à eux.
Et c'est l'extinction des émotions,
l'extinction de l'expérience
qui inquiète plus que tout autre chose.
Et lire un livre sur le faucon pèlerin,
ces joyaux d'écriture
restent avec moi et deviennent
globalisé. Et en fait, la carte physique
est remplacée par Google Earth et le
téléphone mobile. Au lieu de regarder la
nature
sans médiation, on essaie de la regarder
à travers un objectif,
une lentille,
à travers une cartographie
qui n'est pas réelle du tout.
une cartographie artificielle. C'est une
myopie, un aveuglement que nous avons
au lieu de regarder le monde
si on le regarde,
c'est vraiment enthousiasment
et de ne pas le voir, c'est tragique. et
en espérant que mon travail et en créant
des mots qui vont tenter de décrire ces
états positifs, on en a pas parlé dans
cette interview, mais on a parlé de le
tiera qui est un sentiment
positif, qui est un sentiment d'unité
avec la terre
et cette expérience océanique que les
surfeers, les frodiens et certains
mystiques
ressente. Cette expérience océanique
nécessite que l'on fasse attention à ce
qui se produit dans le monde, avoir de
l'empathie et de leur rejoindre cette
eierie,
d'avoir ce sentiment positif et
réconfortant d'unité.
Il y a pas de lien entre l'inconnu et le
connu.
J'ouvre j'ouvre une petite parenthèse
entre vous et moi.
Le cannabis, qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez ?
Je l'ai essayé
jeune homme
mais bon ça
ça un produit quelque chose sur mon
appétit.
Ça permet l'appréciation de la musique
de façon utopique
au-delà du normal,
au-delà de ce que l'on peut attendre de
certains points de vue. Donc lorsque je
reviens à l'état normal,
un état non augmenté de la connaissance,
je suis un peu déçu du fait que la
réalité ne corresponde plus à l'utopie.
Mais après un certain temps, je me suis
rendu compte que la réalité c'est tout
ce que j'avais et que l'utopie était une
forme d'échappatoire.
et j'essaie d'éviter
dans ma vie adulte excepter un bon verre
de vin rouge.
Donc notre dernière question encore un
conseil pour les jeunes générations.
Je pense
rebeller est le cœur de ce que je
pourrais suggérer.
Distinction, rébellion
et Greta sont sur le bon chemin.
J'ai pris part aux grèves des écoles à
Newcastle, la ville la plus proche de
l'endroit où je vis et je vois dans la
jeunesse
et en particulier
une vision du futur
au moins semblable à ce que j'ai moi
avec le symbios.
un rejet du présent et du passé et un
désir intense de se voir dans un avenir
qu'ils creront eux-mêmes,
qu'ils seront avec qu'ils seront à
l'aise, même plus que à l'aise, plus que
confortable qui les enthousiasmera.
Je pense que ce sont des homo sapiens
véritables qui utiliseront
l'intelligence d'une manière que les
autres ont
échoué à faire. Nous avons brûlé, fait
exploser des choses. Ce qui n'est pas
une avancée par rapport à l'âge de
pierre.
les brûlements, les explosions,
c'est un
la génération qui veut utiliser
l'intelligence
qu'à l'être humain sont sur un chemin
différent
tel que décrit par Naomy Klein et
d'autres, c'est que c'est un moment de
changement. Ils n'ent aucune part dans
le présent. Ils ne possèdent rien. Ils
peuvent voir que l'avenir
de routinier est destructeur.
Je n'ai aucun conseil à leur donner. Ils
savent très bien où aller.
Si je pouvais
un moment penser que le symbiè est un
avenir que j'aimerais avoir.
Avoir une vision d'un avenir désirable,
il faut travailler dur pour y arriver.
Si vous vous rebellez sans vision d'une
alternative au présent,
c'est contre-productif
parce que contre quoi vous rebellez-vous
?
Vers quoi voulez-vous aller si c'est
simplement une transition et que c'est
pas une rébellion ? Vous devez avoir une
vision de l'avenir,
sinon ça sera un rêve creux de ce qui
serait meilleur que le présent.
Ce que je vois comme
c'est pas un avis, un conseil,
c'est ce qu'il y a dans le symbios.
On ne peut pas s'en sortir. C'est un
endroit où on aimerait rester pour
toujours.
Donc ça a le potentiel de d'amener à un
processus d'innovation sans fin, mais il
faut énormément de travail sans fin.
Il n'y a pas de chômage dans le symbiè.
C'est une vision de l'avenir qui vaut la
peine d'être adopté.
Vous savez un avenir dystopien d'être
assis dans un coin et de se frapper la
tête,
abandonner
l'espoir,
accepter le deuil. Non, c'est
l'acceptation de ce que j'ai déjà dit.
Je suis en faveur de ceux qui résistent
et probablement si cette résistance a
besoin d'une aide
d'un vieux baby boomer, je serais très
heureux de leur offrir.
Les forces qui me restent et bien elles
seront dédiées à eux.
Clen Albrecht, merci.
Merci de m'avoir invité.
et à votre programme qui est vraiment un
défi en soi.
[Musique]